foi porque minha irmã comprou o carro do
cara mano aí o carro vem com barulho
macho um rangido
aí ela ligou pro [ __ ] porque tá com
uma zoada eu tô andando no carro e tá
com as rodas eu queria saber qual o
problema ele o problema é o som que tá
baixo
[Risadas]
e assim nós vamos começando mais um
gravar
não mais um dia se quiser jogar
de frente agora a gente tá indo para
Nova casa
essa casa aqui é minha mas agora a gente
vai sair da minha para uma da produção
mesmo entendeu
agora vamos sair de uma que é minha para
casa da produção
vem fazer show negócio né
fica todo mundo tá na casa do índice
vai para uma casa vamos ver como é que é
essa aqui é a casa que a gente vai ficar
o resto do mês
[Música]
que que você achou da casa
e você não sabe que tá chegando já já
Opa tudo bom Eita dona Mônica
misericórdia
pensando que é um bichinho
que eu falo acho que eu não falo nada
toda vez que eu vejo o mar eu acho muito
bonito
toda vez que eu vejo o mar Eu Fico
calado que parece que até tão
pequenininho
que nada que a gente falar
Vai importar nesse momento você vai
ficar de boa
curtir a vibe não cortar a lombra
que onda meu irmão não sei se isso é
Qual é a língua né não sei dizer
é um plástico que vai bater aqui na
praia de Fortaleza
asiático
[Música]
chegou olha como é que ela já está
aqui ai o ciúme rapaz
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vai Regina sem paciência já nem luta
mais bebezão
Ele tem muito ciúme é só falar com a
Regina vai para perto
porta bem levinha
[Música]
mas eu não vejo mais o pivete bom que
existe em mim
[Música]
[Aplausos]
venha buscar o Robson que o Robson caiu
do caminhão da mudança
[Música]
é um Riacho mano aí é o
Riachão Regis
dá para pousar
um arrozinho bem molinho assim
chegamos depois de 4 horas e meia de
viagem
passamos por Piripiri
[Música]
aí ó saladinha
baiãozinho com arroz misturado mesmo vai
tudo lá dentro meu filho
macaxeira
Canoa cenoura
[Música]
E aí Batista
[Risadas]
de moletom eu lembro tu lembro do dia
que o Manoel chegou careca lá em casa
e hoje termina mais um dia agora é hora
de tomar banho né finalmente está todo
mundo tendo comentário que nós estamos
com as mesmas roupas de sempre não
esquece de clicar em gostei
e de comentar aí embaixo que que você
quer ver aqui hein você quer ver por
aqui a gente tá aí ele tem muita munição
clique em gostei amanhã no mesmo a
madrugada você que é do corujão Não
esquece de dar RT no Twitter nisso aqui
tá vamos criar uma comunidade da
madrugada até a próxima amanhã E assiste
os de trás que esse aqui
[Música]
esse é o quarto Olha aí esse aqui é o
quarto meu filho é porque teve o
terceiro segundo e o primeiro senão esse
seria o primeiro vai lá